et on dirait que dans cette édition jean
paul stahl professeur spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses et tropicales au
chu de grenoble bonjour jean paul stahl
merci de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france donc une communication trop
anxiogène de la part du gouvernement
c'est ce que disait cette tribune jeudi
matin aujourd'hui donc au lendemain de
la prise de parole de jean castex
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
le discours du premier ministre hier
anxiogène prudent réaliste réaliste
c'est à dire que il est absolument
impossible et il était responsable de
dire que tout ce passe bien tout va
aller bien il ya aucun problème
c'est faux c'est absolument faux le
virus circule circule de plus en plus
infects de plus en plus de personnes et
dans les hôpitaux
quelles que soient les régions on voit
maintenant remonter le niveau de
spécialisation y compris en animation
chez dans un chu en deux jours on a eu
une une montée extraordinaire du nombre
du nombre de carrés spécialisés y
compris de cas graves
donc je crois alors après anxiogène pas
anxiogène je crois qu'il faut simplement
regarder les choses en face
c'est à dire que le virus circule le
virus est dangereux le virus tue les
personnes qui sont à risque ni et cela
est parfaitement irresponsable
d'ailleurs dans la tribune que vous
évoquez je remarque qu'il n'y a pas un
seul pas un seul spécialiste de maladies
infectieuses 10e ou de microbiologie moi
je me permettrai pas de porter des des
jugements sur la médecine du sport par
exemple j'ai une parfaite incompétence
dans le domaine je crois que les autres
personnes ont parfaitement le droit de
s'exprimer en tant que citoyen mais
n'ont pas à se prévaloir d'une qualité
de spécialiste mais justement pour
revenir sur cette tribune et par rapport
à la communication gouvernementale qu
est ce qu il faudrait adopter selon vous
pour à la fois informer et appelé à la
vigilance sans verser dans un
en lalart l'alarmisme non plus à ça
c'est un problème de communication et de
type de communication je n'ai pas de
diplôme de communication donc je
regarderai de dire n'importe quoi
simplement le ce qu'ont constaté on l'a
constaté depuis longtemps pour les
vaccins et donné un petit peu dans la
même mouvance
c'est à dire que c'est un peu les mêmes
populations qui sont anti vaccins qui
sont anti masque jeu c'est l'obligation
qui a résolu le problème pour les
enfants malheureusement on est en france
pour ce point de vue là et heureusement
pour d'autres aspects mais pour cet
aspect là c'est vrai que l'on est assez
différent des anglo saxons ou des
scandinaves qui n'ont pas besoin de
l'obligation pour se conformer à des
mesures de bon sens parce qu'en fait on
est dans des mesures de bon sens le vous
le virus qui se transmet d'individu à
individu est donc tout ce qu'il rompt le
contact entre les individus
que ce soit la distance où que ce soit
le masque et d'une bonne chose le dans
cette tribune le conseil scientifique
est directement visé est ce que le
conseil scientifique a commis des
erreurs
ce qu'il faut dissoudre le conseil
scientifique à entendre cette tribune
preuve les erreurs tout le sait pas
forcément des erreurs c'est des
évolutions c'est à dire que fort
heureusement le conseil scientifique en
rend compte l'évolution de la
connaissance pour recommander des
mesures qui s'adapte à ces nouvelles
connaissances
ça c'est le propre d'une je dirais d'une
action raisonnable sens et est
responsable
non sincèrement ce genre de tribunes
réflète une opinion d'une partie de la
population d'une partie de des citoyens
mais encore une fois ce n'est en aucune
façon une tribune de spécialistes
d'ailleurs même relativement peu de
médecins dans des signataires vous
parlez dans votre service d'une
augmentation de calme de cas graves
selon l'épidémiologiste catherine hill
d'ici huit semaines il y aura
véritablement beaucoup de personnes en
réanimation autant qu'au mois d'avril
est ce que vous partagez cette cette
analyse elle l'a dit au micro d'europe 1
tout à l'heure et du coup cette question
est ce que les services hospitaliers
sont prêts alors je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas parce que ça dépend de nous ça
dépend de nous tous c'est à dire soit on
verse dans le principe le masque sert à
rien c'est une maladie pas grave
et là c'est une catastrophe qui va
arriver une deuxième catastrophe sur le
contraire on est responsable et on
applique les mesures de bon sens qui
sont le qui sont simple à énoncer entre
gap et là on n'aura pas la catastrophe
les stalles et les services hospitaliers
sont prêts et oui bien sûr nous sommes
prêts parce que nous avons déjà
l'expérience de la première vague ou
tout au moins du premier flot de
patients donc on est mieux organisé
on sais mieux comment traiter les
patients on sait mieux faire la part
entre ce qu'ils doivent être
impérativement hospitalisés et ceux qui
peuvent être soignés à domicile
donc je pense que les le système de
santé et cas et mieux et plus capable
d'absorber le nombre de malades mais
évidemment si le nombre de malades
augmente au delà des capacités
matérielles
ça sera une catastrophe merci jean
pascal d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses et
tropicales au chu de grenoble